what happened to vulnerable girls here
in Rochdale but in Rotherham and Telford
as well at the hands of grooming gangs
was simply appalling now last year I
said that if I became prime minister I
wanted to take decisive action to stamp
out this evil and that's what we're
announcing today a new expert police-led
task force tougher sentencing and a new
legal Duty on those working with
children to report abuse I won't rest
until we make sure that our children can
grow up in an environment that's safe
and secure but the language of this
announcement is interesting and it's
drawn a bit of criticism hasn't it we
have the Home Secretary yesterday
talking about British Asian gangs in
particular and you'll know that the data
shows that the vast majority of
perpetrators in this area are actually
white men under 30. Chief prosecutors
say that it's a distraction to focus on
this particular ethnicity group and the
nspcc aren't happy about it why are you
focusing in on this one the data shows
that it's actually not how it pans out
well all forms of child sexual
exploitation carried out by whoever are
horrific and wrong but with the specific
issue of grooming gangs we've had
several independent inquiries look at
the incidents here in Rochdale but in
Rotherham and Telford and what's clear
is that when victims and other
whistleblowers came forward their claims
were often ignored by Social Workers
Local politicians or even the police and
the reason that they were ignored were
due to cultural sensitivity and
political crackness now that's not right
these crimes are horrific and that's why
the actions that we're announcing today
are right and they have been welcomed by
people and I've been speaking to
survivors today and others involved they
will make a big difference in helping us
root out the evil perpetrated by
grooming gangs yeah but why is the Home
Secretary talking specifically about
targeting British Asian gangs when the
figures are just not borne out by that
there's not a disproportionate amount
the British Asian gangs perpetrating
this crime so why is the Home Secretary
honing in on that in particular
forms of child sexual exploitation and
abuse are wrong wherever they happen and
perpetrated by whoever with a specific
issue of grooming gangs in particular
what we've had inquiries independent
inquiries into the incidences at
Rochdale Rotherham Telford it is clear
that when victims or whistleblowers
raise concerns with people those
concerns were ignored and often the
reasons that they were ignored were put
down to people wanting to be not
culturally insensitive or because of
political correctness and that's not
right it can't be right that people's
claims are ignored because of those
reasons so it's right that we focus on
this the new expert police-led task
force that's been created today will
have far better use of data and
analytics to identify perpetrators so we
can stop this awful crime from happening
in the future because sadly it is still
happening and we're not going to rest
until we make sure that all our
communities are safe for young girls why
do you need more evidence to introduce
to introduce the mandatory reporting we
have had a all public inquiry on this
do you accept
in all honesty that the government have
been quite slow to act on this you're
only announcing this now there's been a
public inquiry into mandatory reporting
labor recommended it 10 years ago do you
accept that the government have been
slower than they should have been well
last year I said that if I became prime
minister this is something that I would
act on and I've been prime minister a
few months and we are taking decisive
action today to root out the evil by
perpetrated by grooming gangs we've got
tougher sentencing we've got a new
police task force and yes we're
responding to the recommendation of an
independent inquiry to introduce a legal
Duty on those working with children to
report abuse now it's important that we
get that right and we will work with all
the agencies involved to make sure we
Implement that in a way that is
practical and effective but it's right
that we respond to the independent
inquiries recommendation and I'm pleased
that we're putting that in place today
so you don't you don't accept criticism
that the government's dragged its feet
in getting a grips with child sexual
exploitation given that the big events
happened a decade ago I said I I when I
I said last year before I became prime
minister that if I did become Prime
Minister I would take decisive action uh
to clamp out the evil caused and
perpetrated by grooming gangs today's
announcements represent the most robust
response of any government to tackle
this awful crime would have tougher
sentencing we're having a new police-led
expert task force and a legal Duty on
those working with children to report
abuse together with better use of data
and analytics and making sure that
political correctness and cultural
sensitivities don't stand in the way of
keeping young girls in particular safe
that's very important to me I said it
was last year I'm acting on it today I
just have one more question be prime
minister do you actually know how many
sex abusers operate in grooming gangs
I said you know the scale of that yeah
sadly as we know from the Independent
report that have been concluded this is
happening in communities up and down our
country
do you know the numbers that's why we
need to do a better job we don't know
the numbers because it's not reported
and that's part of why what we're
putting in place today is to make it
easier for people to come forward and
part of who I've been talking to today
whether that's MPC seeing others is
making it easier for whistleblowers to
come forward and Report these awful
crimes because too often in the past
they didn't because they feared what
would happen to them they feared that
they wouldn't be taken seriously they
were afraid of offending people that's
all wrong and that's why one of the
things that we're introducing today is
strengthening the whistleblowing hotline
so that people can report these crimes
and introducing a legal Duty on those
working with children to also report an
abuse so that we can properly identify
all the people who are suffering and
then go after them and make sure that we
root out this evil I must ask you about
teachers
um they've rejected that offer what's
your reaction to that and are you really
considering taking away that one
thousand pound one-off payment well I'm
extremely disappointed with the actions
of the Neu teaching Union the government
after dialogue made what I considered to
be a very reasonable payoffer worth
around eight percent on average for a
teacher and up to 13 for new teachers
combined with working with the unions to
reduce the workload and burden on
teachers something that they had asked
for and in spite of all of that and I
said very reasonable offer on pay the
Neu reunion has rejected that announced
new strike dates which will be
enormously damaging to our children who
have already suffered their education
has already suffered as a result of
covert and the run-up to exams to hear
about new strike dates in the face of
what is a very reasonable payoff that I
think is extremely disappointing is
Jillian Keegan thinks that the
government are considering removing
taking away that one thousand pound
one-off payment is or is that an option
as I said we've made a very reasonable
payoff for worth around eight percent on
average for teachers rather 13 for new
teachers combined with reductions on
workload and for the Neu teaching Union
to be striking in the face of that and
impacting children's education
particularly in the run-up exams is
extremely disappointing thank you very
much